CBS News senior national security
analyst says Fran Townsend is a former
homeland security advisor to President
George W Bush she joins us at the table
to discuss hello July 4th of all days it
seems like a big ole in-your-face move
has this changed the game do you think
it absolutely has changed the game look
they had this was a successful
intercontinental ballistic missile
launch that means it has a what further
range than anything ups now we knew they
had medium and short-range missiles
which were much more of a regional
threat this now represents a direct
threat to the United States and so we're
gonna have to do things differently
sanctions alone have not worked and I
think it's the timing of it allows the
president now to put this at the top of
his agenda in his g20 meetings but it
should say it's it's a big step yet to
say once you've got the missile to be
able to successfully marry the nuclear
warhead and have a successful launch the
question though Fran is you say
sanctions don't work and we have to do
something what what is that
well so we have to get our you know the
other countries to care about this as
much as we do you know I think it's it
it isn't right to say that it's not it
you know North Korea doesn't represent a
regional threat during the Bush
administration we pushed quite hard to
get our regional partners to pay more
attention to this China is going to have
to really seriously implement the reason
we're hearing president Trump's unhappy
is we know that 80% of the sort of
supply chain into the program in North
Korea comes through China still but what
incentives is China have to do something
what they're doing right now right you
just heard the experts say they don't
care it's not their problem well we
should be honest about why China is not
incentivized right China has always
cared about the US presence on the
peninsula and so their great fear is an
increased US presence if the North
Korean government Falls and so instead
of dancing around that issue we're going
to have to put that on the table while
still reassuring our South Korean allies
and so it's a delicate dance but it's
time you know what we've been doing all
along has it worked and so we're gonna
have to be willing to put put new things
on the table past presidents have tried
diplomacy it hasn't worked there are
28,000 US troops on that border
we know in the past ten years it's
heavily-armed that demilitarized zone so
where do you go then it's diplomacy
really an option here
well diplomacy alone and diplomacy with
sanctions alone has not worked right and
we ought to be honest with ourselves I
do think it underscores the importance
of the Fed the missile defense system
that we put in we've been putting in for
South Korea I also think the thing we
haven't talked about yet is the
importance of our missile intercept
capability and so it may be the North
Koreans ought to be prepared the next
time they do just a missile launch
the United States might try to use its
capability to intercept but no-one's
fully confident those intercepts are
gonna work I mean I did try the ICBM a
couple of weeks ago and they said it
worked but that was designed to succeed
that's right that's right and so I think
what you're gonna see in Congress and
here in the United States is a real call
to put further investment in that
technology okay Fran Townsend thank you
very much